jojo was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute geht es mal wieder wie könnte es
anders sein um pokémon go ich werde euch
heute nämlich die nach meinen
erfahrungen effektivste methode zeigen
mit der man in pokémon gold level kriegt
also experience ich bin schon level 17
bei pokémon go also ich hab schon ein
bisschen gesuchte in den letzten tagen
aber das wisst ja und ja ich zeige euch
jetzt eine methode mit der ich innerhalb
von einer stunde 25.000 xp bekommen habe
zum vergleich 25.000 xp sind so viel wie
man von level 1 bis level 8 insgesamt
sammelt also das ist extrem viel und ja
ich gleich wie das funktioniert bei
schritt nummer eins geht es um poker
stopps poggersdorf sind ja diese
sehenswürdigkeiten oder punkte generell
wo man sich poker bälle und trinke und
belebe und sonstwas ab und kam auf der
karte und ihr müsst bei punkt eins
maximal viele boxenstopps kriegen das
macht ihr indem ihr mit dem auto keine
ahnung mit einem freund zusammen oder
auch auf der rückbank wenn eure eltern
fahren einfach in die stadt fährt dort
alles ab fand am besten in die
innenstadt weil klassischerweise sind in
der innenstadt die meisten
sehenswürdigkeiten und halt alles durch
fand ich hab die letzten tage auch ein
bisschen aufgenommen und zeigt euch
immer wieder wie das aussehen würde
also ihr vater halt irgendwie bei mir
sind es jetzt fünf minuten oder sieben
minuten in die stadt rein nimmt halt
alle poker stopps mit dies gibt und
zweimal zuerst mal eine vernünftige
anzahl an po quellen also ich hab so auf
dem weg in die stadt ich weiß nicht so
10.15 poker stoffs innerhalb von sieben
minuten abgefahren was hat schon mega
krass ist und ja dann seid ihr in der
stadt so in der stadt angekommen sucht
ihr euch eine ecke raus wo ihr möglichst
viele poker stopps auf einmal erreichen
könnt ich habe da eine gefunden da kann
man drei poker stopps auf einmal
erreichen was halt mega krass ist junge
und dann nehmt ihr jeden dieser fokus
bei jeweils wie gesagt drei und packt in
jeden ein log modulreihen blog module
ziehen halt pokémon aus der umgebung an
und relativ viele und wenn ich halt drei
stück parallel laufen habe com hat
unendlich viele pokemon falls ihr sohn
nicht auf dem hohen level seit und kein
geld ausgeben wollt ist passiert auch
mega häufig das heißt solche taktiken
schon angewandt werden bei mir zum
beispiel weist so ich bin hingefahren
und habe direkt gesehen und jede waren
drei doch module aktiv und ich musste
selbst nicht ein tun
und ja das lohnt sich halt extrem und
dann seid ihr für die dauer des lok
modus also eine halbe stunde dort und
fangt halt so viele pokémon whisky die
meisten sind dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche taub siehst was aber für
die tak die relativ gut ist ja dann
fangt ihr taxis und was auch immer geht
ich glaube ich habe da in einer halben
stunde irgendwie 40 pokémon gefangen
oder so unter anderem parkplatz in der
nähe habe ich dann auch ein electric
gefangen
richtig krank auf 805 oder so was ich
habe es ja normal eingeblendet auf jeden
fall ja die dann eine halbe stunde
verbracht mit pokemon fangen und dann
fahrt ihr nach hause
logischerweise nehmt ihr auf dem rückweg
wieder so viele boxenstopps und was da
auf dem weg ist ein pokemon auch mit und
dann habt ihr so eine halbe stunde
ungefähr verbracht zu hause angekommen
braucht ihr das lucky eck und müsst das
aktivieren
dann kriegt ihr für eine halbe stunde
doppelte xp und dann müsst ihr einfach
innerhalb dieser halben stunde alle von
den pokémon bei mir waren es irgendwie
cvp oder so die ich gefangen hatte alle
entwickeln und man kriegt die
normalerweise für eine entwicklung 500
xp und mit dem lucky kriegt man tausende
xp was hat unglaublich viel ist weil
wenn du normales pokémon fängst kriegst
du jahrhundert also das zehnfache und
dann entwickelst du entwickelst du
entwickelst du entwickelst du
entwickelst du
bei mir waren das irgendwie 17 minuten
oder so die ich einfach nur mit
entwickeln zu gebracht habe
und dann klickst du auf exit und siehst
die glorreiche zahl 25.000 und das
innerhalb von einer stunde pokémon go
also ich fand es mega kraft und das ist
in meinen augen mit abstand die
effektivste taktik ihr müsst halt nicht
mal selbst immer diesellok module kaufen
geschweige denn die glücks eier weil die
kriegt man ja eh auf dem einen oder
anderen level up also ich habe mir noch
nie irgendwas gekauft bei dem spiel
und bei diesen besonderen ecken wo halt
richtig viele fokus ob sind die man
erreichen kann so eine ecke muss man
erst mal finden sind auch meistens schon
lockt module installiert also mit dieser
taktik könnt ihr extrem schnell level
und bekannterweise wenn ihr auf eine
höhere level seid könnt ihr auch besser
pokemon fangen und ihr wollt gute
pokémon fangen ja das war so mein tipp
für euch wie ihr richtig effektiv im
pokémon go level könnt und ja ich
wünsche euch viel spaß dabei ich gehe
heute abend tatsächlich mit ein paar
freunden treffen in seinem biergarten
und dann gehen wir zu dieser ecke wo man
drei poker spots auf einmal erreicht
nachts gut heute tief